to make it easy to synchronize the audio
and video later except that's not really
an answer to the question is it if the
question was why do YouTubers clap at
the start of their recordings then yes
that's the answer it's to help with
synchronization a lot of the time audio
and video being recorded separately the
microphone on my collar is sending its
signal to a small and very beef nut
recorder that's clipped to my back
pocket the camera is recording its own
sound too and saving that as part of the
video file on its memory card but it
sounds terrible so when I'm working on
the edit and putting the two files back
together it's really useful to have a
short loud impulse sound at the start of
both files so I can synchronize them
just by looking for the spike on the
display there's a couple of extra
complications there though first of all
should that synchronization be perfect
that camera's about two meters away from
me the speed of sound changes a little
with temperature but roughly that's
about six or seven milliseconds not
enough to care about here but once you
start putting the camera further away 10
or 20 meters for long shots that sound
can take a couple of frames to reach the
camera and the audience that would feel
weird so I'd have to slip the audio a
little that's why it's worth double
checking the synchronization by looking
for the frame of video where the hands
touch
plus some cameras particularly old
GoPros actually add some sound delay to
the video file the synchronization is
terrible so if I've got three or ten or
a hundred different cameras or looking
at the same thing I can use that clap to
synchronize them all get it close by
looking for the spike confirm it by
looking at the hands actually worst case
the audio can actually be late by up to
maybe three frames or so and the chances
are no one will mind or even notice
actually the sound on this video has
been three frames later ever since I cut
back to this shot of me if you did
actually notice well done I'll put it
back to normal now I suspect that works
because brains are used to correcting
the small speed of sound lags for people
shouting from a distance but that's just
speculation I can't actually finally
research to back that up and because the
viewer might have things like a cheap
external sound bar and a television that
adds more lag it's best to synchronize
as close as you can if the production's
got a high budget or they might use a
Clapper board instead that means the
editor has a record of which file is
which take of which scene at the start
and they can sync up the audio at the
same time but all that is still not an
answer to the question it's the answer
everyone gives but it's not what the
title of this video is actually asking
this isn't why do YouTubers clap at the
start of recordings it's why do
YouTubers clap at the start of videos
I've done that plenty of times before I
did it in this video why do we leave a
bit of technical junk in there why do I
set up a really nice shot and then ruin
it by showing the setup part like my
camera fuzz about with the autofocus and
make the whole video
worse
well I can't speak for everyone but my
reason is it sets the audience's
expectations and it makes it feel more
authentic while I'm filming on my own
with a static camera it can sometimes
look like I'm just stood against a green
screen but clapping walking into frames
letting the focus settle showing that
behind the scenes moment it proves I'm
here it makes me seem more trustworthy
for someone vlogging from the bedroom
keeping those claps and the preparation
in letting the audience see a little bit
of the slip-ups and how it's made it
helps make a connection helps make them
relatable
I don't need to be relatable I don't
really want to be relatable but
trustworthy trustworthy is good and
leaving the clap and the walk in the
video established that I am one person
with one camera that I don't have a crew
on this shoot and that I am actually
here wherever here is sometimes I'll
leave that in when I actually do have a
crew
it's all about the Aesthetics showing
that setup leaving that synchronization
clap in it's about fitting the message
to the medium planning not just what you
want to say but the subtext of how you
say it and handling all the subtle cues
that connect performer to audience and
say it's okay
you can trust me